[Music]
hey
good morning party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries the old
guard uh i'm spencer j gilbert here with
daniel radford and mr lon harris
uh we are going to take you through our
thought process on the trailer
we're gonna all watch it together we're
gonna watch some deleted scenes respond
to uh
what we like to call viewer mail even
though they're just angry comments you
wrote underneath the video
and then we will uh uh we're gonna tease
next week's on this trailer which is
gonna be a fun one
um i think that covers it so yeah
way back when like a week or two ago we
watched the old guard
and it was fine what did you guys think
about it
you know of the charlize theron plays a
person who can't die because they've had
super powers for like uh millennia uh
movies this is my second favorite of
that genre that she's number one
uh the my first one yeah uh i i i
cracked the the one with will smith
hancock that's my first oh yeah okay
they're also like super heroic god type
creatures in that one i think yeah yeah
that's their whole deal is that they're
like they're from these this like mystic
line of
games who like can't die and like he
can't remember things because uh at one
point racism happened and then stopped
happening
um just for that one second though uh uh
just long enough for him to lose his
memory
wow big spoilers um we should do hancock
one of these days that was a that was a
too soon movie i think yes that was a
two-stool movie for sure that one
and um what was it like my crazy super
ex-girlfriend or whatever
yeah it's just my super ex-girlfriend i
think it's that one but yeah like
hancock was it was
i think they sold it as like a comedy
and then it was such a big idea movie
i think people didn't really know what
to do with it but maybe today it would
make more sense
yeah and i think that that's and the old
guard i you know i really i really
enjoyed it it is
very um it's slightly too grim dark for
me
but that might just be like where my
head is at um but i did i think it was
like
it's a really good movie for a netflix
movie especially
and i enjoyed it is it like uh
the best thing that happened to me uh
you know in the last like five years in
movies no
is it as good as we're going to get in
2020 yeah man suck it up
exactly i i think it's really important
or i'm unable to separate how i feel
about this movie
with the context that i saw it in which
is the service that i already paid for
um it popped up and uh i enjoyed the
the two hours i spent with it but if i
had plunked down
15 bucks or whatever to go see this at a
movie theater and
it ended with that rampant sequel bait
and
looked kind of low budge you know
shelley's i love her
she carries the film uh completely but
not not enough for a fiat theatrical
experience
but i think just right for uh for an
evening in yeah
it's a real mixed bag i mean like the
action is really good
charlize is good i like the other camera
like i like you know i like the team
i it just it feels like if there's a big
movie inside of it that's being like
forced into like you know like like
office space you know like i just it
just feels like like this is such a huge
concept and it's it's obviously like
franchise potential and
it's being squeezed into this like
little version of itself
yeah the premise of it itself the
premise lends itself to like an
expansive history spanning epic
and you get that in flashbacks and
montages of them yeah
and it's always like that one time in
history we were all in a field
you know yeah i want bill and ted's
excellent adventure i'm gonna go chop
their way
through every historical era but right
but we've got mostly 20
uh 20 teens uh europe it's like really
nice to have a
movie that's new and also like you well
no and it's like it sounds like that's
me being weird
and snarky but we're talking about the
context of things i just uh
uh i give me anything at this point and
i'll put it right in my eyeballs because
we need new things we we
done run out of things unless we all
want to go back and just watch the
office again which apparently all of you
are doing
um i need to get on that train but yeah
like it was just
i'm just i'm excited for a new movie you
guys uh uh they said new mutants it's
the only thing
i mean it was it was a movie it was
certainly a movie
and i i should i should clarify because
maybe people will be yelling at us maybe
not i don't know how popular it was but
i don't think any of us have read the
source material for this one right
you did i have not oh okay so how
closely does it hew to that
um there are some changes um but yeah
it's pretty close and
um with the sequel bait i mean yeah but
also uh
it depends on because this is a real
umbrella academy situation where it's
like i'm interested to see
what they take from the next uh bit of
source material and what they decide to
leave behind
um so i'm trying very carefully
i don't want to say because sometimes
like these movies or these these things
they will adapt something
some things from a season in the first
bit and then
leave those other things for like later
so i don't want to be that guy
um but yeah it diverged some definitely
for sure
i'm interested to see what they do with
the next bit i'm kind of
it's comforting to know that that
stuff's already been written so they can
either choose to do it or not do it but
at least you know that like hey there
is another part of this that works yeah
this is a graphic novel so it's also
like you said cramming a bunch of stuff
into like
oh good so like it doesn't it has an
ending and everything
i don't think it's ended um but there
are i believe there are two
maybe three books out now um but it's
it's a series i mean it's a series of
graphic novels that's how i read it but
i think it was
probably a monthly and greg rucka who
wrote the graphic novels
also adapted the script for this and is
working on the film so they're probably
going to keep roughly to the story or
he's got ideas of ways he wants to sort
of tweak it along the way
well cool yeah i mean i i i guess it's
in the right place with netflix i hope
that they
give them the money to expand uh on this
and like
you you never know with them they might
be like well the people who are going to
sign up to watch us already signed up so
let's have them let's set the next one
in a uh in an elevator
we're in this elevator and we can't die
yeah it definitely
feels like this was if people liked this
this was supposed to open up like a
bigger me i'm hopeful that with this
getting so much heat and popularity at
least at first
they'll yeah that's if this was a movie
where they charged people to walk
through the door
that would be the case but this is
netflix where it's like they just need
to string you along just enough till
your next hit
this was probably three seasons worth of
budget for them and we all know that's
where they say uh no thank you
goodbye you get the x you get the
charlie's axe
uh all right well let's dive into our
honest trailer for the old guard we'll
have more to say then
lon where are you by the way i'm on the
set of the old guard right now
this is where they shot the big action
sequence
conference room 6de got it i am on the
set of the door guard as you can see
behind me and then over here
i'm in fandom headquarters right now
all right let's go
[Music]
from the streaming studio with an
infinite money code
comes a film made for the new home of
action blockbusters
your couch the old guard
you see it's so sad but
awesome i can't decide where it's like i
watched the first 30 minutes of this
movie i paused it
i made dinner i ate dinner put the kid
to sleep
went back and watched the rest of it
it's like what uh
you never get to do that with uh in 1982
or whatever you're going to see over the
top you can't pause in the middle of a
truck stop scene and then go fix
yourself a meal and come back
it breaks the flow but i admit i i try
not to do that with movies like with tv
shows
whatever it's over i'm going to pause it
when i need to but with movies
especially the first time i'm watching
them i really try to like
dim the lights and sit down and not stop
and like treat it like a movie because
you're right
the constant temptation is there to like
let me just check twitter
like let me take a you know go get some
a snack or whatever
i'll do that after an act i know what
accent i don't want to knock break it
always take a second i'll take a second
i'll throw some stuff in the insta pot
check up on it because not all netflix
movies are created equal
you know like oh well that's for sure
that's for sure like i don't treat
everyone like a premiere or just because
it's on netflix like sometimes
i split the irishman into a couple days
but anyways
the irishman was a couple days i'm sorry
i like that movie a lot that is
i have adhd i know tear up tear my film
i
i i uh i took an intermission i didn't i
did an irishman in russia it took like
an hour
it was like like you gotta have let's go
out to the movies and make ourselves a
snack or a full dinner
if you are sponsoring a cocktail so it's
a lot it's a lot about labor relations i
need a break
all right keep going you see netflix
turn out disposable rom-coms
oscar baiting dramas and the home movies
from adam sandler's least hilarious
vacations
now whatever he either used to make
programming decisions
has found a new way to make you look up
from your phone for two minutes so they
can count it as a view
take an a-less star and cram them into a
b-movie action flick
nope not that one not that one not that
one
not that one there it is as the studio
spends big money
six underground can we tell they can't
they can't possibly have felt like that
was a good investment
it's like what a 200 million dollar
michael bay movie
i love that movie so much i can't even
i'm sorry i can't
it was goofy and ridiculous and i
enjoyed it but like come on nobody's
talking about 600 guys get completely
forgotten already i do have i have
complicated feelings about six
underground like
for one it's um to me it's it's just a
scotch better than a transformers movie
because the action was certainly better
but they really got
uh um in their own way with the
non-linear storytelling of that
there's no reason for that don't
complicate things you're not hiding
anything
there's no reason for half of the
decisions that happen in that movie and
yet they happen
and they spend so much money but i think
it would have been like
a better not rock level but a better
action movie if it
had played uh in order there was no
reason to chop up time that way
it honestly feels like michael bay
watched uh pulp fiction
and was like no let's try it you know
watch this you can see
a good movie i watched it because i
wanted that movie it's not good
but there were parts of what i like the
the car chase at the beginning fantastic
the
magnet yacht fight at the end fantastic
it's also it's one of the his best uses
of you know like michael bay has that
like extreme
gore thing like i'm just going to do a
traditional action movie scene but then
just like a head's going to explode
there's going to be corpses everywhere
and 6 underground is maybe like peak
just random gross random with ryan
reynolds cracking jokes about it yeah
and like that
i don't know for some reason that
appeals to me on some level just the
fact that he like
doesn't care and it's just like
needlessly super violent
that's the only but i don't like is the
gore that takes me out of it because i'm
like
this is so fun and then now there's like
a head all right no it is
crazy like i'm not defending it and any
like bad boys too is like this too where
you're just like
why is it so gross yeah that's how i'm
feeling about
perry mason right now but that's a
that's a separate subject um and also
though what what uh why i have mixed
feelings about this is to me
michael bay doing a netflix movie says
more to me about the
death of cinema than scorsese doing a
netflix movie
like i'm sorry the irishman is fantastic
and a cinematic
uh theatrical experience but that's
all but michael bay without a big screen
like that
that's uh that's like um give me a good
analogy here
that's like a man without a heart
it just it just can't live it's
something is really lost when you do a
200 million dollar action movie
on netflix than when you do a drama on
netflix no matter how
uh aspirational and oscar it's beyonce
coming to your house
to make you food in the instant pot and
it's like well i'm glad that i spent 200
million dollars to have beyonce make me
her favorite meal in my instapot but
also shouldn't you like
be dancing at like a black campus full
of children like i don't understand like
why i paid all of this money
for you to just do this that like yeah
it feels very much like
you can actually like make money for all
of the money that you spend with the
michael bay movie and that is one of
those ones
oh this is not a film critic thing this
is just real guys
there are some movies from directors
that you do kind of have to watch on the
big screen first and we talk so much
about how we're excited for tenet
michael b movies demand being seen on
the big screen
exactly yes explosion yeah it's not even
just i mean it is like the size of
screen
and like sound and all that but it's
also the communal like a michael baby
only makes sense with like a
raucous somebody
i feel kind of the same way like i love
those movies but it's not the same
watching it i've never
like watched more than half of one at
home but it's a it's an appointment
and by dudes i mean the royal dude i
mean of course
the gender neutral version all the dudes
yeah but like right it's like the rock
is gonna like
flex a cast that's gonna explode i need
people cheering for that that can't just
be me
i need several different uh uh ringtones
to go off
throughout the film and like somebody to
turn on their flashlight i need people
around me to be recognizing the
reggaeton artist cameos because i'm not
picking up on those
i need a big pop when don omar shows up
definitely i'm not gonna pick up on don
omar oh that's gasolina like i need that
yes right because i'm like the idiot
all right what movie are we talking
about today
let's watch the old guys that's kind of
how we felt while watching the old guard
as the studio spends big money on talent
and uses whatever's left to cram action
into an affordably tiny space
don't you guys want to go fight outside
such a nice day
meet the old guard a team of immortal
mercenaries who can revive
themselves with the power of moaning and
grunting real hard
just got to resurrect my pancreas real
quick
crap rebirth cramp these illuminati
i guess you hear like them plink down to
the ground but i figured they'd be like
full of bullets their bodies would just
have
tons of bullets inside of them that
would get that one wolverine shot i
think
joe or or nikki that like you see the
bullet like
pop out yeah so like it is happening but
they don't the whole just like squeezes
it
back out right yeah yeah yeah all right
there is nothing that's safer work that
happened in the last minute that's all
i'm gonna say
[Laughter]
all right let's go these illumi hotties
have lived for hundreds to thousands of
years with a burning desire to do good
even though they're really bad at it
we've done
nothing the world isn't getting any
better it's getting
worse because instead they spent an
eternity learning krav maga
boning celebrities is this the rodent
did you know him
probably biblically and developing their
palette hazelnut not walnut
black sea rose water pomegranate
eastern turkey
of all the things to do with immortal
life
this really did bug me about this movie
that it's like if you lived forever
you'd develop so many wheat like think
about just the older people that you
know like who've been around for 30 40
years
they're collecting stamps is collecting
knowledge they would have the skills
they would have developed the
how about like put some money in the
stock market my god they should all be
trillionaires they should have money on
the cubbies
yeah no it's it's like uh like i kept
thinking of that jarmoosh film only
lovers left alive where tom hiddleston
and tilda swinton are
immortal vampires and they've been
around for like a couple hundred years
and like that's the whole point of the
movie is like their houses are crammed
with like stuff and they got in all this
weird music and they've read all these
crazy books and
they can't talk to anybody because their
references are so
out of control and it's like oh my god
you just described me on a date
are you immortal just like constantly
talking about the simpsons and like
making other references and it's like i
don't know what you're saying i'm taking
like i just kept waiting i'm going to
look like this forever
this face is immortal body might not be
i'm going to look like this
well it's fine you went with the uh the
highbrow jim jarmusch
uh version i was like they're like the
vampire council from blade
but it's the same like it's that that
idea that you imagine like if you were
immortal
you know you would be sure sometimes
you're doing mercenary stuff but other
times you're just
like hanging around and like they have
little references like booker
i guess likes books she gives them don
quixote at one point
and like she likes desserts and rodin
but like
i i thought there would be a lot more of
that kind of stuff it would be fun
little
insufferable at trivia yeah like here i
think i picked this trick up in the 17th
century you know like where was like
there was nothing like that
which one of them would have gotten
super into close-up magic
all of them at some point how many
lifetimes before you uh resort to that
you gotta have a low point during
i mean maybe that's like history nerd
stuff and there's no room for it because
it's an action movie but
even like we mentioned in the trailer
like even like they don't seem to have
really studied up on like military
tactics or how to like not just like
wander into an angel
just action stuff of like oh i know
ninjutsu i know
uh about every single weapon ever made
right
all these things but oh well maybe in
the sequel anyways keep going
they're not even that good at fighting
normies get the drop on them all the
time
that tracks they wouldn't have to be
good they could just throw their dead
bodies at people
yeah but it hurts right like you still
not want to get murdered
yeah yeah i don't like stubbing my toe
it won't kill me but i mean we just did
that whole montage of like
like you would you would have you would
do your best to avoid that happening
every time there all right anyways keep
going
this is just poor immortal time
management the
team leader andy in a role that lets
sharlee stretch her range from world
weary
we can do something good some good means
nothing too exhausted
i gave up searching for her to a mean
old rumplestiltskin
the world can burn for all i care as she
straddles the crossroads of being the
next keanu reeves
or being the next gerard butler of
action movies
suicide squad featuring newcomer nile
a marine trained in exposition so why is
this happening to me how are you holding
my dreams
what's happening booger who likes books
oh first edition don quixote and a pair
of passionately meeting the warrior
lovers
he's the moon when i'm lost in darkness
and warmth when i shiver in cold in his
case still thrills me even after
millennia
oh my god it's so gay i'm gay it's too
gay single negative
couple
gay or not like i'm in a very long-term
relationship and it's like
after they're all negating each other
after hundreds of years
yeah hundreds of years make fun of your
partner and how like
that's all you and your partner do and
it's cute and it's flirty and you love
it
you're not sitting there reciting poetry
to each other
look after like three weeks all you want
to talk about is like dude you farted on
me last night like that
is what you talk about what's for dinner
did you put the things into the insta
pot like those are your conversations
it's not like oh i'm gonna like i'm
gonna put like this rose in my mouth and
we're
to talk about like these deep like
soliloquies and all of this stuff yeah
you're a stone cold psychopath if you're
still doing the the rose in the mouth um
like to the level that they do which is
not like special occasions this is
just their patter back and forth was um
my god
what's their secret good for them uh
anyways
[Music]
yeah it's like the movie not really
thinking at all like what would it
really be like to be with these people
over
hundreds of years it does it kind of
feels like they all just started doing
this
it would be hot couple bickering that is
what hot couples do it's bickering it's
cute
definitely okay keep going
kill me together charlize's angels will
find their very own bosley
and unite to take down a guy who
combines the dickishness of mark
zuckerberg from the social network
with the wardrobe of justin timberlake
from the social network
so strapping us something we didn't get
into
in this trailer um and i posed to the
panel here not to get too like
trolley problem on you but is the bad
guy really that bad in this movie
even if he i'm sorry even if he kills uh
five innocent people to literally end
disease and dying among all of humanity
is that bad what's weird to me is then
is that they didn't like they didn't
think of this
verse like yeah like they wanted half of
them want to die anyways
yeah like should we find like you would
think earlier on
in the development of science and
medicine they would be like should we
find somebody that we can work with
we can like you know who won't like
kidnap us we can like donate
plasma to and they could try to figure
out what's going on like
it seems like this would be a good thing
for them to motivate on
like on their own without needing just
figured out what cells were
that's pretty tight uh do you want to
just like cut off potter like like a
little
tab maybe we should learn to be
scientists during one of our infinite
lifetimes
like knocked on jonas salk's door like
you seem like a good dude
here's the deal you know like why wait
for martin shkreli to kidnap you
look he had a lot of time in between
waiting for exclusive wu-tang albums
but i do agree this is one of those i
mean look obviously like the idea of
killing people to get that knowledge is
bad but the idea of a
billionaire actually caring about saving
lives and and putting a lot of resources
into it when a lot of them could just do
that right now that's fantastic
yeah um and then you know they try to
create a reality
fantasy film if they try to justify it
yeah it's so unbelievable
they justify by saying well look at how
many like people you've killed
not killed saved throughout the ages and
how that's echoed and rippled but it's
like
also the people you've killed i'm sure
has echoed and rippled throughout time
like maybe that goon that was working
for the pharmaceutical company like
maybe they
gave birth to somebody who would help
like if it cuts both ways
right yeah also again y'all could have
been the best scientist like
if you're angry because this 50 year old
or are trying to like people are trying
to get like these 50 to 60 year olds who
have like these mega degrees to help you
when you have been alive for all of the
time
the whole time just hundreds if not
thousands i mean they could have like
gone to see isaac newton and been like
what's up man like teach me some stuff
like they
did the opportunities depending on your
area of interest and they
literally just used it for like let's
find like the funkiest coolest looking
weapons we can
no one made them turn into murderers
that was their choice
on the other hand but but
you can tell where a nut came from in
your mouth why am i doing this do i wait
care
all right let's keep playing so strap
in for a history spanning epic full of
intense action scenes
except the heroes have every advantage
and the villains are chump underdogs
with zero chance
that proves an all-female crew behind
the camera can get it done
just as well as the fellas but due to
the realities of streaming budgets
mostly takes place in small rooms next
to something more exciting
i thought you said we were going to
paris we're just outside of paris i
found ladders
just outside of london what is this
place an abandoned mine
wow and pumps the brakes on the thrills
to set up some seats
just really quick pause uh uh can we
please give uh uh all of the people on
this crew an actual budget so they don't
have to just
tell us about places that are cool we
could go there
but i feel like that's it they almost
hung uh the lantern up but like
that's what chirons are for or whatever
it just could be like outside london
saint truth
yeah the movie feels oddly
self-conscious like it knows that it
wants to be able to take you to cooler
places and it can't so they're always
like
explaining why like oh we have to hang
out in this cave
because it's my old hideout or like yeah
we use this as a safe house
it's in the middle of nowhere and it's
like i don't know i feel like they do
kind of call attention to it in a weird
way but
it's also just a shame like well if this
was got to be
the bigger movie it was supposed to she
had like this she has entire lifetimes
to create like the coolest hideout ever
like
it would be incredible um yeah i mean
i mean i think you know the team was
right the cast is right the story's
right it's like so much
was right but then they they got like
one-third of the amount of money they
really needed to pull this off and they
do they do a really good job with what
they have like
like there's a lot of cool stuff in this
movie and cool sequence of the action is
great uh i would like to see a sequel
but
as it is frustrating on that level and
you know how long did the new york uh
subway system take that's all i'm saying
just uh
yeah all right let's finish up
and pumps the brakes on the thrills to
set up some sequels
cause netflix's skynet has already
foreseen this will become your new
favorite franchise
and resistance is futile then let's go
to work
but hey we all love shirley's their own
and axes what could go wrong
right oh that's nice starring
shirley's eon if beale street couldn't
die
schmidt everlasting jafar and away the
cutest
mediterranean sniper she would tell
edgier gourd
pharma bro and iron man
excellent bad boys
i'm excited for her to come in the in
the sequel a real
see that's why you carry around a little
notebook to jot ideas down on the go
yeah that's really sad about their uh
the big line before they go
charge the final stand of bad guys is go
big or go home
that is that to me will always be
associated with the disney original
movie johnny tsunami
where uh the kid from hawaii moves to
the
mountain resort and has to the big
conflict is having to go from surfing to
snowboarding
and he falls in with a group of uh rap
scallions whose
slogan is go big or go home um so maybe
she saw that in her cave
maybe she had the big shell vhs of
johnny maybe she had an affair with the
creator of johnny tsunami and she
inspired him as opposed to the other way
around you don't know right
you're right you're right she could have
invented that people are amuses i am
like look that that whole
uh the iron uh the iron the lady in the
iron mask uh
is incredibly cool and i'm very much i
liked that scene
the post-credit not post-credit
post-credit scene where it's like we get
to see more of her that's really dope
but i'm actually very excited for that
yeah well that i don't think that's like
she's the one she's like kelly marie
tran's sister from the end of last
jedi and she's also she was just in the
five bloods she's the like
miss saigon like radio propaganda lady
she's like popping up in cool world and
she's also in this uh vietnamese
i think it's called maria it's really
cool vietnamese action
film she's like a martial arts star so
she's like bubbling
up to the back she's gonna get her
breakthrough one of these days
so like maybe it'll be old guard too i
don't know awesome
all right uh well that's the old guard
let's take a let's take a quick moment
to
thank you guys for watching thank you so
much for tuning in every day or just
today but make a habit of it subscribe
to the channel
uh hit the like button and the bell that
helps all of us
help us help you uh we also did another
video today uh where we kind of
used a criteria to break down which of
the netflix original action movies are
worth watching
uh the answer may not surprise you or it
will i don't know how familiar with
those but just
watch the night comes for us for god's
sake it's so good
the veronica no movie is called fury i'm
sorry it's not necessary okay
uh so yeah watch that video see where
all the other ones shake out and which
ones are worth your time
um and now let's see what we cut out of
this trailer
uh who am i kidding viral mortal i've
spent all my time getting high and
playing video games
i mean what's the rush starring
geriatric blonde emperator furioda
national security senior trip death
becomes her
alternate universal soldier we have no
choice but to afghanistan
casual noobs book of the undead
booker d halfwit this guy fawkes
napoleonic complex drinker traitor
soldier spy
the joe logan experience they keep
joeing and
joeing and joeing and joeing crusader
zim
get a room my wife who's the bosley
wall of crazy dudley dursley
dudley do wrong heal or no deal
mark zucker-dursley martin skilly
dr quinn menacing woman the get drown
and dead to me get her to the ancient
greek
the great great great great great
grandparent trap
the unbreakables
so andy's so paranoid about being
recognized that she doesn't even like to
appear in the background of tourist
photos but still pick the most
distinctive looking weapon in the entire
history of weapons
solid strategy can't imagine why our
plans have it all worked out
andy now can regenerate from all wounds
but both of them have earrings
how does that work boy i hope somebody
got fired for that blunder
that's very clever i did not i that's
the first time i've seen that deleted
clip and the first time i've ever
actually put that
put that connection together if you keep
a thing oh gosh darn it danielle if you
keep a thing in a hole it's going to not
heal
up around it if you
i'm muted i feel like all wounds uh
sustained
stick around oh maybe that's that's
that's that's my her immortality kicked
in
yeah it doesn't really leave if you
leave it in and then you can just keep
poking it in and then it heals around it
and then it's like
healed you know tattoos might be a
problem right the only thing that didn't
make it into the trailer that i
didn't love about this film uh was the
like
kind of like speaking of six underground
the like sneaker pimpsy
uh uh mixtape that would play during
some of the action scenes yeah like
kind of like uh like lo-fi hip-hop
lounge music
like uh like portis head or something
would start playing
oh i see i i love both sneakers i do too
i just don't think it was a great
page yeah it wasn't a perfect
match for me of of action and music it
was kind of like a spotify generated
playlist right that's an interesting
point to raise because we all the time
have jokes and observations about music
and scores that we kind of it's hard to
put those into it on australia
because we can't play the song yeah
because we don't have the rights
uh we're where i won't give away what
we're working on we're working on a show
on this trailer right now that has a lot
of really lame needle drops and i had a
whole bit
written about it before i was like oh we
won't be able to it's like the one thing
they have like the half of youtube's
budget goes towards uh just
destroying the the life friends and
family of anybody who
uploads copyright music really cannot
impress upon you guys how many times we
have joked about something in the room
or have wanted to write a bit about
something where we're like
can we get a sound alike can we do
something that sounds because this is
such a big sometimes even the sound alex
gets
flagged yeah
the last parody one we did the parodies
got flagged i forget which one it was
but it was stuff where we had an
original person maybe
we still had to like go through the
whole process to prove it ridiculous and
we're like
writing like we're writing those lyrics
music yeah we get the music
made we uh we write the lyrics
25 of the jokes that we yeah that we
want to make i'm like literally 25
especially if it's a tv show is us
wanting to make fun of the music and
being like we can't tell any of those
jokes we should yeah
yeah i think about it uh well um
all right let's see what uh the people
had to say about this uh
francisco writes in regards to this is
just poor immortal time management
i feel it's quite realistic humans have
pretty short lives but we still
procrastinate
a lot so imagine how much time they'd
waste when they have literally all the
time in the world
yeah that's true you might take a
lifetime off yeah you gotta budget in
like jerking around of course like i'm
not saying that that's not
part of what they're doing but hundreds
of years like think about how much
you've learned and
all of the things that you've done and
experienced an accident in just like a
decade and then like multiply that by
like a thousand
or like me a few hundred i don't know uh
james bunt writes uh in the comics the
older ones couldn't keep up with
technology like cell phones
that's interesting so they're just like
ah it's the parchment it's fine with me
we don't need to
we don't need to change this you might
get set in your ways after millennia
of not using technology it might take
you a hundred years to pick it up it'd
be interesting if you're like you still
like your taste
in music was formed when you were a
teenager and that's it like no matter
how much
yeah it's like the clavinet where's the
harpsichord
if i have to learn what a billy eilish
is then they have to learn how to talk
i'm sorry like i i know megan the
stallion so they can adjust as well
they're just constantly accusing people
of witchcraft it's like it's
2010 yeah it's a camera you've been
around for hundreds of years now
uh langley neely what's up langley
writes uh uh regarding the villain he
wasn't trying to be altruistic he wanted
all the cures for profit
which is true i mean he was in the uk so
that's the nhs you know you probably
have to
probably have to share i don't know is
that how real healthcare works
why would we know that but even in his
ultimate villain moment like at the end
when he's like revealing
the whole plan like he's still not like
i just want it for myself like he's at
least pretending like i feel like on
some level he believes that he's being
altruistic
even if at core he's just a greedy
person well he definitely does and if
you're playing villains that is the best
way to go about it is to be like hey
like
i am doing the world a good thing and if
i happen to make enough money to once
again be able to buy an exclusive
wu-tang album
then i can do that who needs instagram
holdy writes i just watched the honest
trailer is that pharma guy harry
potter's cousin yes it is indeed dudley
dirty
and i think they they did that on
purpose like they cast a
recognizable villain so that you already
don't instantly hate that guy
you know what i'm going to push back on
the idea that uh dudley dursley is
recognizable
i don't even think you necessarily are
like that's dudley you just have a bad
feeling about that guy i know that guy
from somewhere i don't like
oh he seems like a bad egg because even
if not
even if he was if he'd still look the
way he looked when he was a kid it would
be like oh i think that might be deadly
dursley
but he had one of those like harry
potter cast glow ups
where like he doesn't look like the same
dude anymore really i immediately
clocked dudley dursley
and i'm not even like the hugest
potterhead but i was like
they put dudley in this he must be the
bad guy
uh matthew zecharesh writes did they
resolve if spencer is a vampire he was
spammy mailed about how to become undead
a year ago and we never got a follow-up
uh i believe since uh uh the birth of my
child i have aged
decades so no i'm clearly not a vampire
uh uh everything's falling off um and
lisa martini writes uh hey lisa hello my
lovelies
just made a prawn red curry and got
slightly carried away on the chili been
crying my eyes out and coughing for five
minutes straight
well thank you for watching anyways lisa
i appreciate that just take a little bit
of it and put it on some rice you're
fine the rice
yeah i had um some leftover hot chicken
tenders this morning and
had kind of the same reaction um because
it only gets spicier
uh the longer you wait the longer it
marinates than that and milk is a lie
i'm sorry they keep telling you do milk
milk is like not that doesn't mean
arizona i shook it off and did this show
so good there's a thai restaurant on
sunset that i used to go to that makes
this amazing pork dish but it's
too spicy for me and even if you're like
hey make it less spicy they like just
don't
which one that's
called you know it's the one that's
right by that arby's on sunset like
your siren studios that's what i started
to go there because we used to work
there
uh the jungle curry at jitlada this is a
good
conversation to have on camera let's see
people are gonna love it but anyway
i still eat it because it's so delicious
but i have this exact same reaction for
like two hours afterwards i'm just like
it really wakes you up in the morning
but um that's all for us today i hope
you enjoyed us talking about the old
guard
and uh midtown la thai restaurants
thank you danielle thank you lon and
thank you audience for being with us
please join us
next week um for something uh
uh that'll bring uh it'll bring everyone
to the yard i think
or no no wait that's is that is that the
right one no i'm i'm switching these
things around uh
so next week uh you know
something that should make uh all the
queen bees in the audience proud
there you go yeah yes uh thanks for
watching we'll see you again
tomorrow bye
[Music]
you